it's lance mcculler's junior on the
mound for the astros today and mccullers
he's facing the mariners for the third
time in his last four starts through
five shutout innings in seattle on
tuesday jp crawford leads it off to two
swing and a miss crawford goes down on
the curve ball emma cullers picks up the
strikeout to start the ball game
left-hander you say kikuchi on the mound
for seattle and the astros have seen him
a lot they've seen him when he's been
really good they've seen him when he's
been not so good
and that'll bring up left fielder your
don alvarez
two outs nobody on here's the pitch of
the way swinging a pop-up into left
field and coming in is bowers and jake
is there to make the catch and that's
going to retire the side a quick bottom
of the first inning for you kikuchi so
the bases remain loaded for the number
nine hitter switch hitting catcher cal
raleigh he'll bat left-handed against
mccullers raleigh batting 163 214 on
base percentage a home run and 11 rbis
he's looking to shake an o for 15.
three infielders in the triangle right
side bregman even with third and way off
the line 2-2 to raleigh
curveball grounded into the shift
fielded by altuve shuffling to his left
and short right and he throws out
raleigh to end the inning
lance mccullers loads the bases with one
out of the mariners get nothing and
after an inning and a half astros
nothing mariners nothing led me diaz
stands in he's the d.h today
but the base is loaded and nobody out
infield back for the mariners in a
scoreless game diaz hitless in his last
22 at bats hitting 277 on the year 327
on base percentage seven homers 38 runs
batted in 2-2
and that's a ground ball right side and
it's booted by toro and kicks into
center field correa scores curiel scores
tucker goes to third two to nothing
astros
hit sharply and it just got too deep on
toro he let it get too deep so runners
at the corner still nobody out and
here's jake myers the center fielder
is getting the start in center field
coming off a road trip where he hit 300
he drives one deep to left field forget
about it
three run bomb by the rookie jake myers
and the astros jump out in front five to
nothing fourth home run
in the young big league career of jake
myers
there's alvarez ninth man the bat in the
frame he flied out to left his first
time
2-1 and alvarez whistles this one deep
to right center field and that's going
to get down for a base hit and go all
the way to the wall altuve scores
alvarez trades places with him he's at
second with an rbi double six-nothing
astros
eurodon's 90th run bad at end of the
season and scott service has seen enough
two on two away six nothing houston and
the banner will be first baseman yuli
guriel
alvarez at second correa the runner at
first base the stretch by sheffield and
now the lefties pitch on the way to
guriel swinging a broken back ground
ball up the middle off to his left j.p
crawford he's got it keeps on going
steps on second himself for the force on
correa and that will finally end the
bottom of the second
so runners on second third up by six
here's france he walked his last time up
here's the one two
fastball got him strike three on the
corner france looking for the breaking
ball and he got the express
there's abraham toro switch hitter
batting left
another one two to toro
shoots this down the line and a fair
ball into the corner mariners
are getting on the board
crawford and henniger are in and the
former astro and his old stomping
grounds
abraham toro a two-run double so now
it's another lefty marmalajos with the
runner in scoring position 6-2 lead
here comes the 0-1
another breaking ball hit into shallow
left coming in a couple of steps alvarez
jordan puts it away with two hands
and that'll do it for seattle they get
two runs two hits one man left we play
two and a half astros lead at six to two
here's maldonado the catcher
banning out of the nine spot
and sheffield checks the runner comes to
the plate pitch fastball swing on and
sent deep to right field but hanniger's
got a beat on it step from the track
makes the catch and that will do it for
the astros no runs ahead neuers and one
man left three complete it's the astros
six demerits two kellnick singled his
last time up
here's the one two
change up got him strike three kelnick
right through it
third strikeout for mccullars and
there's one away raleigh is their
catcher he grounded that to second bases
last time up that was with the bases
loaded raleigh the big lefty at the
plate
and that is a strikeout tip foul into
the catcher's glove another curveball
and it's a one two three inning for
mccullers he's got four strikeouts in
the ball game and we played three and a
half in houston the astros lead six to
two here's alex bregman here's the
stretch and the 1-1 to alex bregman on
the way swinging a line like it all yeah
line drive to short and coming up to
make the catch on the fly is jp crawford
i thought it might take a short hop but
jp
charging that line drive made the catch
sliding in
6-2 houston bottom of the fourth that'll
bring up shortstop carlos correa justice
from the belt and the 3-1 pitch
to correa fastball swinging it's popped
up
shallow right center field over his
mitch haniger henniger is there and he
makes the catch and that's going to
retire the side in an outstanding job by
sheffield he pinches around that
lead-off double by jose altuve who
stranded at seven one out no one on for
mitch hanigar he singled and scored in
the third
one for two here's the one-two
swing and a miss good slider down and
away and hanniker's down on strikes
fifth k for mccullers two out
so one out still two men in scoring
position for jake myers
2-2
and myers skies this one in the center a
late break for kelnick racing in and
that's going to drop for a base hit
coming in the score is guriel and the
astros now lead 7-2
and now it's altuve's turn
he has a pair of doubles and a walk
tonight
the pitch
bouncing ball at the third base line off
the heel of seeger's glove bobbles it
with his bare hand and the astros get
another run as tucker comes home
it's eight to two you're don alvarez the
big left-handed hitter for the astros
one for three with an rbi double
here's the stretch and the 2-2 on the
way fastball strike three called he
strikes out alvarez looking and that
will finally retire the side
france walked in the second struck out
looking in the third
here's the 1-1
and that's line down the left field line
alvarez racing over and he'll have to
play that off the base of the out of
town scoreboard france going for second
the throw in the slide france is out
malayos the left-handed hitting
designated hitter also plays in left
field and can play first base
two
swing and a miss good morning good
afternoon and good night jose marmaleo's
got him on the hook
six strikeout for lance two out so toro
is still at first for kel nick who's one
for two with a single
now the one two
swing and a miss got him on a change up
away
seven strikeouts for lance and he
strands a runner
we're through five and a half astros
eight
mariners two
runners at the corners no one out for
and he drills this one into left center
field that will be down for a hit past
the diving jared kellnick correa scores
here comes guerrielle he'll be waived
home he's going to score two rbi double
for kyle tucker that's his 30th double
and the astros in double figures 10 to
2.
and the astros have loaded them up for
bregman here's the 01 to bregman
and alex lines this one into center
field that'll drop in front of kellnick
tucker scores diaz stops at third astros
lead 11-2
alex bregman his first hit at rbi of the
night and now you got to deal with
alvarez with the bases loaded nowhere to
put him
he struck out first time and he swings
and
pops it up
medium center field taking charges
bowers calls everybody else off and
that'll bring up jake myers
2-2 pitch
take it for a call strike three
and that'll do it it's the slider top of
the zone gets myers looking now it's
france who is singled and walked he's
one for two little one two
that's a hard shot backhanded by
gonzalez spins throws a second for one
altuve on the first that's a double play
foreign gonzalez's first chance
back with the astros is a sensational
one
and for the second straight inning belak
hits inning in the double play
cal raleigh stands in
he is over three astros leading 11 to
two
and that's a ground ball right side
backhanded by eule goes a second for one
correa on the first and guriel covers
and that is the ball game a 3-6-3 double
play to end it